não só os governos a mais no vídeo 2000
em sinal de como fazer uma máquina que
corta espero vita e fez elas servem
pensada para cortar as asas como esta
aqui uma vez que eu quero ensinar como
fazer um avião telecomandado em breve
[Música]
é
o
com um só
[Música]
o
é
[Música]
o
não só temos assim espero que vocês
tenham gostado deste projecto que seja
útil precificado feito para só adicionar
um potenciômetro só como eu não tenho
aqui vou te ensinar mais tarde mas só se
estiver em casa eles são vicente o
controle desta forma vocês vão conseguir
controlar a intensidade de corrente e
está pronto muito obrigado até a próxima
etapa